i used to only write parodies and uh the
idea that i could write a song
and change the words and have you guys
go home and sing the words that i sang
makes me made me giggle
so i had done some research a couple
years ago online and i found out that
there were guys out there who had tiny
penises
and um imagine those guys get to have
sex every now and then i also imagine
that that sex is probably pretty awkward
for everybody involved
so this is a song about a dude with a
tiny penis having awkward sex and it's
from his point of view and this song is
not about me okay here we go
and guys if you don't laugh at this
we're all gonna assume why so
yuck it up you tiny dick [ __ ]
here we go
song about a dude tiny penis awkward sex
his point of view
not about me
ready go
[Music]
say something i'm right on top of you
[Music]
be patient i haven't hit my groove
[Music]
the least you could do is kind of move
[Music]
please say something i am inside of you
am i am i
am i really that small
i've been told that it's skinny but it's
strong and it won't hurt you at all
i
[Music]
memory that's small
maybe your vagina's kinda big
like throwing a hot dog down a hall
[Music]
a lot more laughs on the [ __ ] little
dick joke i'll tell you what
little dick ha ha ha everybody
big [ __ ] [ __ ] you pal
[Applause]
a lot of smart guys not laughing too i
saw that
yeah listen sometimes the little p and
the big v
are not good matches everybody it's
called physics
or biology you know what it is i'll tell
you what it is
some of you aren't gonna like this but
i'm gonna tell you what it is
it's the big p and the little p and the
big v
they're like getting the last bit of
mayonnaise out of the jar
game
[Music]
i told you some of you weren't gonna
like that
somebody liked it a lot i appreciate
that
all right i remember the rest of that
[Music]
song
[Music]
[Music]
you